tout public sénat comme le sénat où
l'assemblée nationale le parlement
européen est composé de différents
groupes politiques
une fois élu après les élections de juin
2009 les députés des 27 états membres
vont donc rejoindre l'un de ces groupes
en fonction de leurs affinités
politiques
mais attention un groupe ce n'est pas un
parti alors pour simplifier un groupe
comprend des députés appartenant ou non
à des partis politiques européens ou
nationaux
le parlement européen est composé
aujourd'hui de sept groupes politiques
ces groupes politiques représentent des
des tendances partisanes tels qu'on les
trouve dans les différents états membres
à titre d'exemple le ppe le parti
populaire européen le groupe majoritaire
aujourd'hui au sein du parlement
européen
il se situe à droite de l'échiquier
politique
on trouve également le parti socialiste
européen qui comme son nom l'indiqué
regroupe l'ensemble des participants des
états membres le groupe des écologistes
verts le groupe des libéraux qui se
singularise par une sorte de de
brouillage un petit peu idéologique
entre le centre-droit et la droite
libérale
on peut penser également à la gauche
unitaire qui regroupe les partis
d'extrême gauche par exemple parti
communiste français ou encore dan quê
allemand pour ce qui concerne la france
l'ump se retrouve au sein du parti
populaire européen
le modèle au sein du groupe des libéraux
le parti socialiste français au sein du
groupe du parti socialiste européen le
parti des écologistes se retrouvent
évidemment au sein du
du groupe politique des verts les
présidents des principaux groupes
politiques au sein du parlement européen
sont pour le ppe joseph daul qui est
français martin schulz pour les
socialistes qui est allemand
monica frassoni et daniel cohn bendit
qui copréside le groupe politique des
verts au sein du pe et graham watson le
britannique qui préside le groupe des
libéraux il fallait jusque là vingt
députés de six pays différents pour
constituer un groupe
mais la règle vient de changer après
juin 2009
il faudra au minimum 25 députés de sept
pays différents pour constituer un
groupe politique au parlement européen
c'est toute la question de savoir si les
conservateurs britanniques qui
aujourd'hui sont membres du parti
populaire européen vont faire scission
donc vont affaiblir le parti populaire
européen et vont réussir à créer ou pas
un nouveau groupe politique non
seulement avec les tchèques de la ds
avec les polonais du pis mais aussi pour
que ce groupe soit rendue possible avec
d'autres d'autres partis dans d'autres
états membres et à ce stade
à ce jour il est difficile de savoir si
cette condition visant à réunir un nom
de l'état suffisamment important sera
réuni ou non plus un groupe est
important plus il pèse au moment du vote
dans l'hémicycle
les groupes ont aussi davantage de
moyens pour travailler il dispose d'un
secrétariat de facilités administratives
et de crédits prévus au budget du
parlement
si vous êtes dans un groupe politique
alors vous avez accès à la répartition
des postes clés de la machine
parlementaire la présidence les
vice-présidences surtout les commissions
les présidences de commissions qui sont
absolument cardinal la commission étant
le mode d'existence le plus important du
parlement 736 députés sont élus en juin
prochain mais il faudra attendre le 14
juillet jour de la première session
parlementaire pour connaître la
composition de ce nouveau parlement
européen